let's face it anime is home to some of
the biggest arrogant characters in media
i know you agree and these guys simply
carry with them undeniable charisma that
makes you just want to cheer them on or
get their asses handed to them your
mileage may vary but to me there seems
to be no in between on another note it
seems so satisfying when said arrogant
characters get humbled in the biggest
possible ways that's what we're looking
at today i'll be listing my favorite
moments in anime when the arrogant
character gets destroyed and put in his
place let's start with anas versus
zeppelins
[Music]
it's such a great feeling to be able to
talk about misfit of demon king academy
again it's a really fun show that wastes
no time telling us what it's about how
does it do so by giving us this kind of
introduction with the arrogant zepez
being utterly destroyed by our
protagonist and anas doesn't just kill
zebras mind you without even touching
his opponent anas repeatedly kills and
resurrects zeppes quite literally toying
with him and flexing his power again and
again what i won't say it's super
satisfying to see zepez finding grovel
because we barely knew anyone is still a
big way to make a first impression it's
a sign of things to come as misfit of
demon king academy goes all the way in
integrating the whole one punch man
thing into the show still it's got some
great story developments that keep it
from going stale with the second season
on the horizon it's the best time to get
into the series
it's appropriate to follow an
announcement with a kirito moment
as a villain oberon has one job be a
hate sync during his time as sword art
online's villain there's nothing
redeemable about oberon or even his real
world counterpart sugo he's there to be
the villain for everyone to hate and
want to see get destroyed so obviously
he had to be this over-the-top arrogant
villain with a god complex oh and he's
quite the controversial figure too
seeing kirito finally destroy him was
nothing short of satisfying never mind
the context that could have confused
anime onlys never mind kirito going
literally god mode for the first time in
the series seeing oberon beg for mercy
before getting annihilated was more than
enough fan service for fans he went out
in the most painful and humiliating way
possible and i know the sao fan
community had nothing but cheers for
this scene
asta vs sekei is a good introduction to
the series
while we're all too focused with arsenal
being noisy at this part of the anime
we've got to admit he plays the lovable
underdog hero well and seky serves as
one of the perfect starter opponents for
the underdog protagonist he's cunning
and is the type of guy who would do
anything just to make himself look good
not exactly the most lovable character
and him singling out our stuff for the
sake of showing off didn't earn him a
lot of fans well anyone who watches
anime could tell this is a disaster
waiting to happen for seki you know he's
doomed the moment he throws up the spell
and dares asked her to attack him easily
one of the worst mistakes he could have
made but it does make me smile to see
him get one shot the guy never saw that
coming and the way he got defeated
should wipe some smugness off him
before gianno and his murders we have
jotaro and his auras in this moment
right here
smug cruel and petty beyond belief
steely dan isn't going to find himself
on many people's favorites list anytime
soon assassinating enya the way he did
won't earn him appeal points and so does
forcing jotaro to obey him in such a
self-indulging way well guy took a
complete 180 the moment his mind control
comes off and as expected you see him go
back to being the sleazy guy that he is
good thing that the protagonists are
ready this time easily dismantling
lovers as the start of his humiliation
to cap it all off we have the legendary
three pages of aura where star platinum
relentlessly barrages steely dan
completely destroying him in the only
way he deserved to go that's 30 seconds
of aura that will forever be
immortalized in anime form
[Music]
skill
[Music]
it's not quite the barrage that star
platinum did but takamura landing the
decisive punch on hawk felt so good
there's just a thing with athletes and
irrational overconfidence isn't there
we've had a fair share of those in real
life but i truly think that hawke puts
those real world athletes to shame maybe
it's his background but having
persevered through such a tough
childhood truly fed that ego of his in
his introduction the show wastes no time
establishing his arrogance it's takamura
he's facing but the guy acts like he's
going toe-to-toe with some random scrub
to be fair he had the skills to back the
arrogance up his fight with takamura was
a back and forth affair with no shortage
of drama and tense moments the two
behemoths collided and completely lived
up to their billing still it's clear who
the anime wants us to root for takamura
is no saint but compared to hawke's
temperament he might as well be one
that's why when hawk finally falls and
subsequently retires from boxing it was
so much joy it's pretty wild to see how
broken he became as a result of this
fight
and hey i know seeing cocky characters
get destroyed is satisfying so
satisfying that few things can top it an
exception of course is being able to get
the best discounts in town and that's
where today sponsors slick deals comes
in slick deals is the free browser
extension that's a shopper's best friend
the extension acts as an aggregator that
compiles numerous deals for items you
may want and give suggestions on the
best possible ones now who wouldn't want
to save money especially at a time like
this when everything starts becoming
more and more expensive heck you can
even get something related to anime the
time list your name for only four
dollars or the whole of cowboy bebop for
the same price
thanks slick deals thanks to an active
community of over 12 million users sneak
deals continues to provide the most
updated information on the best prices
and coupon codes on the internet and if
you're the kind of person who likes the
satisfaction from using coupons for
points then the extension does that for
you if you're a fan of online shopping
and want to have the best experience
doing so don't forget to install this
browser extension use my link in the
description to download the slick deals
extension now
let's end the break with a bang this is
gilgamesh versus shiro at the end of
unlimited blade works
gilgamesh ever since his first
appearance as an archer servant in fate
zero reeks of arrogance those who only
got to know his babylonia incarnation
won't know but trust me longtime fate
fans were quite surprised at the wise
kings temperament which took an about
face from the personality we grew up
with fate zero was filled with gilgamesh
flexing and a kind of hubris that he
easily backs up that's why it all felt
so redeeming to see him fall in
unlimited blade works to shiro of all
people yeah not even a servant but a
human who's actually quite underrated
when you think about it still it was a
big highlight seeing gill slowly lose
his composure in the fight how can the
strongest servant of them all not run
over shiro it all comes full circle
towards the end of the fight even when
back to a corner he refuses to put aside
his arrogance and it's his hesitation
that cost him a hand and the battle
gojo
jojo is next on the list
now here's a turnaround joko is quite
the confident villain as early as his
introduction he's the one with the crazy
suggestions imagine bringing up walking
up to gojo and just killing him outright
to be fair there's some basis to his
confidence though at the start of the
encounter jogo does showcase what he's
capable of and everything from the flame
magic to the bugs looks quite
intimidating and powerful sucks for jogo
though when his opponent decides to take
control of the match it's all over gojo
pulls the ultimate una reverse by using
him as a training dummy as he shows yuji
the extent of his abilities now it's the
mentor's turn to show off his
superiority and showcase his power poor
jogo stood no chance whatsoever and this
whole battle shows why you don't mess
with gojo
[Music]
saitama vs deep sea king is up next
ah one of the most emotional scenes in
one punch man dc king's defeat is one of
my favorite defeats in the series this
guy quickly built a resume early on
beating heroes left and right when even
sonic and genos among all the other
heroes weren't able to defeat him it
understandably inflated that ego of his
he eventually finds his match in the
form of saitama then he foolishly fails
to realize that he's punching way above
his league and continues the trash
talking so saitama responds in the only
way saitama could by defeating him with
one punch ending his reign of terror for
good most people remember this after the
moomin rider moment but i think that the
aspect of it that relates to having an
arrogant villain get destroyed in one
hit was quite underrated after finishing
the anime version of one punch man deep
sea king is still up there in my list of
villains i wanted to see destroyed
luffy delivers a punch that's heard all
over the world for our next moment
[Music]
i know i've talked about this scene
quite a number of times already but how
can i not the celestial dragon just had
one of the most punchable faces out
there and his attitude throughout the
whole ordeal simply doesn't do him any
favors luffy had enough and we've got to
give dudes to the build-up of this scene
you just know that it's coming and
everyone seems to do so everyone except
the ignorant celestial dragon before
getting his brain scrambled and luffy
gave us one of the most satisfying
moments in the one piece anime in a
series as long as one piece has saying a
lot
[Music]
lastly i'd like to end with eins versus
clementine
there are a few people insane enough to
challenge irons to a fight a powerful
and proud warrior clementine is
psychopathic enough to attempt the
impossible and let's just say that it
didn't go all too well for her she may
have had a lot of victories under her
belt but there's only so little one can
do against eins in spite of her martial
arts skills in spite of her proficiency
for battle in spite of all the
preparations she had in spite of her
bloodlust none of those were relevant in
any way when she finds herself facing
the opponent her pride asked for big
mistake normally you'd feel bad for
someone who gets destroyed that badly
then again it's clementine one of the
most arrogant characters the series has
given us so far so we don't need to see
a lot of tears shed in this scene
and that's gonna do it for my list of
arrogant characters getting their
comeuppance which one is your favorite
and which scene would you have added if
you were to make your own list up i'd
love to hear your comments and feedback
so please do so if you have more
interactions with the team in the
community you can drop by the channel's
discord i'll leave a link on the
description box so you can just hop in
and join the fun there's also a patreon
and an instagram for the channel so
please do check those out too and don't
forget to check out our sponsor slick
deal for the best deals and discounts
while shopping online you can download
the extension by using the link in the
description thank you for watching the
video and i hope to see you again for
the next list